years have passed and I still regret not
having the chance to learn these life
realizations
earlier but even with that the more I
listen to them the better my life
becomes and yours can
too just listen
carefully every time you are rejected
from something
good you are redirected to something
better realize you cannot control
everything or
everyone but you can control yourself
and that's even
better just because things could have
been different doesn't mean they'd be
better when writing the story of your
life don't let anyone else hold the
pen
remember some of the best times of your
life haven't even happened
yet if it keeps you happy keep it
quiet know your worth never put yourself
in The Bargain Bin or that's where
others will value
you the magic you are looking for is in
the work you're
avoiding sometimes when you're in a dark
place you think you've been buried but
actually you've been
planted once you realize your value you
will be greatly surprised at what you
use to settle
for the best thing I ever did was stop
telling people what's going on in my
life before you talk
listen before you
react
think before you
spend
earn before you
quit
try many people don't like you
especially if they see you as a
competition always listen to your
gut somehow it knows many things that
you wouldn't
expect rule your life with your mind not
with your
feelings every bad decision we have made
in life there was more emotion in it
than there was mind every single
one over
trusting
betrayal
masturbation loss of
energy
stress hair loss
overthinking depression saying no
important
Revenge ruining your own life
observing increase in
wisdom
forgiving
healing Letting Go peace of
mind you cannot convince people to love
you no one will ever give you love
because you want him or her to give it
real love moves freely in both
directions don't waste your time on
anything else
[Music]
spend your money on the things money can
buy spend your time on the things money
can't
buy life doesn't get easier or more
forgiving we get stronger and more
resilient time truly
flies be grateful always because because
it can always be
worse live like there's no tomorrow and
do what you
love the money will
flow chasing the opposite sex and having
temporary
relationships which means nothing but
sex is
pointless know your worth never put
yourself in The Bargain Bin
or that's where others will value
you if it can be fixed why are you
complaining if it can't be
fixed why are you
complaining if the path before you is
clear you're probably on someone
else's a private life is a happy
life sometimes it feels better not to
talk at all about
anything don't say yes to everyone to
make them
comfortable check with yourself too
before you
commit every person has three faces
firstly the one we show to the world and
Strang ERS secondly the one we show to
family spouses and close friends and
thirdly the one we show only to
ourselves there is a healthy amount of
distrust to have in
everyone nobody's intentions are truly
clear even after being
stated you aren't crazy you're in
intelligent life is not a matter of
holding good
cards but of playing a poor hand
well thousands of candles can be lit
from a single
candle and its life will not get any
shorter happiness doesn't diminish when
you share
it
at first you choose a partner based on
appearance and enjoy it until you
realize that your children will be
raised not based on
appearance but based on
values if you expect the world to be
fair with you because you are fair
you're fooling
yourself that's like expecting the lion
not to eat you because you didn't eat
him
learn how to say it and mean
it resentment is like drinking poison
and then hoping it will kill your
enemies you can always earn money it's
not a big deal your world is not going
to end because you don't have a fixed
income
something else will work
out your friends want you to do good but
not better than
them rest don't
care the average of five is real if you
really want to know someone look at the
five people they talk to the most and
spend the most time
with
if you're trying to break a habit don't
say this is the last time I'm doing it
to
yourself instead say this is the first
time I'm not doing
it beware of little
expenses a small leak will sink a great
ship never compare your life with others
they may seem better than you but they
have some problems which are never ever
heard by
you if they don't have what you want
don't listen to what they
say there's no greater waste of time
than justifying your actions to people
who have a life you don't
want keep to
yourself stay away from
idiots stupidity is
contagious not everything in this world
should be your problem some things are
simply none of your
business focus on the issues that affect
you
directly you will be much happier that
way your value is not determined by
someone else's inability to see your
worth
life can only be understood backward but
it must be lived
forwards don't ignore a problem you see
coming from a mile
away that foresight is a
gift don't squander
it he who laughs at himself never runs
out of things things to laugh
at decision making like coffee needs a
cooling
process don't judge each day by the
Harvest you reap but by the seeds that
you
[Music]
plant with every failure comes the
experience needed to do better
pay close attention to those who say
they love you because so often they
don't they only use
you trust in yourself and your first
instinct on
decisions you spend all your health
initially for wealth and then you spend
all your wealth for one day of good
health
the people who say you can't and you
won't are usually the ones scared that
you
will be careful who you call your
friends I'd rather have four quarters
than 100
pennies you don't have to feel good
about it you just have to keep going the
feeling will pass but you will remain
lower your
expectations having high expectations of
yourself and of others is a recipe for
chronic dissatisfaction in
life your friends problems become your
problems the smaller your Social Circle
the fewer problems you
have today is the oldest you've ever
been in your life and the youngest
you'll ever be
again whatever is begun in Anger ends in
shame don't set yourself on fire to keep
others
warm the only real mistake is the one
from which we learn
nothing
success is 5%
brains and 95%
consistency learn to be
sufficient and realize you are Immortal
who will suffer horribly later if you
don't become independent and
resourceful if you are a so-called night
guy you will be screwed up in the worst
possible way you can ever think
of most people stay in the same place
for a reason the things they hold dear
are the anchors that hold them in
place a ship in the harbor is safe but
that is not what ships are built
for people are great at keeping secrets
they don't
know every person in your life is a
teacher some bring lessons about love
and
support others teach you what to
avoid not everyone wants to see you
succeed some will even go out of their
way to see you
fail if people took back the pain they
caused you you'd lose the strength you
gained don't be afraid of a shadow it
just means there's a light
nearby if you want to get rich think of
saving as
earning
stop worrying about what other people
think honestly who gives a
when you laugh people laugh with
you and when you cry you cry
alone when you try to please everybody
you almost always please
nobody
be
yourself everyone else is already
taken it is possible to commit no
mistakes and still
lose that is not
weakness that is
life don't tell anyone what you think or
what you know keep your secrets to
yourself because a friend of today could
be an enemy by
[Music]
tomorrow a busy man is seldom visited by
idle
friends no flies fly to a Boiling
Pot don't get bogged down in
regrets no one is
perfect don't chase happiness just stay
positive and you will experience
Joy
stop trying to make everyone love you
you need enemies to
succeed if you wouldn't take advice from
them why would you take
criticism everyone falls
down getting back up is how you learn
how to
walk you are not a product of your
circumstances
you are a product of your
decisions focus on you people come and
go no amount of success can compensate
for failure at
home just because you hate this chapter
doesn't mean you'll hate the
book
the more thankful you are the more you
attract things to be thankful
for sometimes the things that break your
heart end up fixing your
vision the person who cares less has the
most power in a
relationship the trouble is you think
you have time
the roots of Education are bitter but
the fruit is
sweet loneliness isn't the absence of
people it's the absence of
connection seek meaningful
interactions not just
company be silent or let thy words be
worth more more than
silence just because a thought got your
attention doesn't mean it deserves your
attention stop telling people everything
most people don't care and some secretly
want you to
fail if something bothers you change it
if it is beyond your control learn to
live live with it accept it change
yourself that is the only thing you can
influence everyone is on their own
Journey focus on
yours you don't notice your progress in
life because you are always raising the
bar there are two wolves fighting inside
all of us
the first one is evil the second one is
good which wolf will
win the one you
feed loneliness is the price you pay
when you start to improve
yourself Embrace judgment no matter your
outcome you'll always be judged so don't
live to impress others live to impress
yourself comparison is the thief of
Joy focus on your path not someone
else's never be so kind you forgot to be
clever and never be so clever you forgot
to be
kind if you don't control your mind
someone else
will luck is what happens when
preparation meets
opportunity wasting time in regretting
cribbing and crying won't fetch you
results life's challenges are not there
to paralyze you but to help you discover
Who You Are
never sacrifice your progress for a
friend they might not do the same if the
tables were
turned don't compare your life to others
you have no idea what their journey is
all
about people will forget what you said
people will forget what you
did but people will never forget how you
made them
feel people never lie so much as before
an election during a war or after a
hunt the more you like yourself the less
you'll need
others to have what you never had you
have to do what you never
did
stay away from people who make you feel
lonely no company is better than a Bad
Company write your sad times in the
sand write your good times in
stone be
kind but don't let people use
you the world doesn't care about your
potential cares about what you've
done you aren't always responsible for
the first thought you have but you are
responsible for the second
one those who have a why to
live can bear with almost
anyhow never underestimate the the power
of stupid
people you are right about all the
things you think you need to do don't
wait get
started knowledge is knowing that a
tomato is a fruit wisdom is not putting
it in a fruit
salad circumstances make
man not man's
circumstances sometimes it's a blessing
to not get what you
want it is better to be hated for what
you are than to be loved for something
you are
not people will say almost anything when
they're happy be wise and careful of
this one
dead people receive more flowers than
the living ones because regret is
stronger than
gratitude a goal is a dream with a
deadline be proud you survived the days
you thought you
couldn't worry is the ultimate bullly
it takes everything and gives
nothing let go or be
dragged great results can be achieved
with small
forces when thinking about life remember
this no amount of guilt can change the
past and no amount of anxiety can change
the future
no one is going to figure out your life
it's your
responsibility rejection is important
for
[Music]
self-development your mind gives up a
lot faster than your
body leave nothing for tomorrow which
can be done today
not everyone will like you that's
life you'll ruin your life trying to
make everyone
happy mistakes are proof that you're
trying love your neighbor as
yourself don't go broke trying to
impress broke
people when you get up in the morning
remember what you promised yourself at
night people don't think about you as
much as you imagine they
do if you have more than three
priorities you have
none a ball doesn't bounce until it hits
the
bottom make peace with your past so it
won't screw up the
present no one has the answer you're
going to spend a lot of time figuring
things
out people don't get what they
deserve the world will not treat you
better just because you're a good
person when nothing can go wrong it
will a calm sea will not make you a
skilled
sailor don't make one person the center
of all your
happiness don't make them the reason why
you are happy because once that person
walks away from your life you left with
nothing you deserve it the career the
love the family the peace the
life don't depend too much on anyone in
this world because even your own shadow
leaves you when you are in
darkness the ego is not a bad thing and
sometimes we need it in order to achieve
our aims and feel
Vitality however the ego is just a tool
we shouldn't let it control
us success is a loner's journey you must
learn to accept loss and make
compromises if you stopped seeing the
world in terms of of what you like and
what you dislike and saw things for what
they truly are in
themselves you would find a great deal
more peace in your
life youth is happy because it has the
capacity to see
beauty anyone who keeps the ability to
see beauty never grows
old the only person with whom you have
to compare ourselves is that you in the
past there will always be someone who is
better than you in something you have to
accept that fact and learn from them
that's something that will help you
grow death does not concern us because
as long as we exist death is not here
and when it does come we no longer exist
you have three choices in life you can
watch things happen make things happen
or wonder what the hell
happened do not dwell in the
past do not dream of the
future concentrate the mind on the
present
moment no work is beneath you the only
thing that should be beneath you is your
big ego work hard in silence and show
your skills at the job you get rather
than criticizing the
job no matter how many times I may
stumble I will rise each time a better
man the most important step a man can
take is the next one it's always the
next one
you might be the sweetest Peach on the
tree but some people just don't like
peaches there are two ways to live your
life one is as though nothing is a
miracle the other is as though
everything is a
miracle if you want to help yourself
find is to carry the spirit of the child
into old age which means never losing
your
enthusiasm Nothing in life that is worth
having comes
easy passion is super awesome but it
doesn't cure all your
problems passion can go a long way in
your life but it doesn't mean it's all
unicorns and rain
bows no is one of the most powerful
words in
existence don't be a people
pleaser the only time you should look
into someone else's bowl is to make sure
they have
enough be not afraid of moving slowly be
only afraid of standing
still
what God doesn't give to you you have to
go and get for
yourself experience is not what happens
to a man it is what a man does with what
happens to
him no matter how nice or respectful you
are some people will still talk bad
about you behind your
back
life is unfair don't moan don't complain
learn to be thick skinned make the most
of what you
can only a fool learns from his own
mistakes the wise man learns from the
mistakes of
others experience don't
expect experience life do not carry
expectations on how it should
be if you change the way you look at
things the things you look at
change when you're working for someone
else's
dream you sacrifice your
own we live in an age when unnecessary
things are are only
Necessities kindness is a language that
the deaf can hear and the blind can
see what people say when they are angry
aren't things they mean they regret it
often forgive angry people it's okay
they are only
human all that we are is the result of
our
thoughts if you are unhappy you are
doing something
wrong he can do
anything who thinks that he can do
anything take time to enjoy life's
Simple
Pleasures it's in these moments that we
are and find the most
Joy just because you know how it's done
doesn't mean it's not
magic live your life as an
exclamation rather than an
explanation no matter what good you do
to people they will only remember your
mistakes
you may not realize this but the people
you love are your biggest
weaknesses well done is better than well
said a man is but the product of his
thoughts what he thinks he
becomes great men are meteors designed
to burn so that Earth may be
lighted someone's opinion of you doesn't
have to become your
reality no one can make you feel
inferior without your
consent sometimes a hypocrite is nothing
more than a man in the process of
changing don't regret the past CU at
that moment you did your
best holding grudges will never harm
people you hate only
you if you can't do it now you won't do
it
ever thinking is difficult that's why
most people
judge the things you own end up owning
you speak your mind even if your voice
shakes this too shall
pass good people do not need laws to
tell them to act
responsibly while bad people will find a
way around the
laws
you are not what happened to
you you are what you chose to
become you are what you do not what you
say you'll
do those who cannot change their minds
cannot change
anything as a child I prayed to God for
a bicycle
then I realized that God works
differently I stole my bike and prayed
for
forgiveness do not envy other people's
good
qualities but instill them in yourself
through
admiration most of the stuff you worry
about never
happens
don't chase women instead focus on your
growth values and cultivating
kindness the right person will find
their way to you at the perfect moment
without the need for
chasing you grow mentally weak when your
life is too
comfortable we have four problems
overthink over Trust
overshare over
love listen more than you speak for
wisdom often comes from
Silence when fate hands you lemons make
[Music]
lemonade the world is boring for boring
people never was anything great achieved
without
danger tough times don't last but tough
people
do there are times when you see someone
for the last time and don't even realize
it watch out you'll never know the true
value of the moment until it becomes a
memory
resentment is like taking poison and
waiting for the other person to
die every person alive hits a Crossroads
in life when you have to let go of the
past and Forge ahe into something
new the only sad thing would be clinging
to the Past once it's Out Of
Reach fiction is the LIE through which
we tell the
truth problems cannot be solved with the
same level of thinking that created
them a friendship founded on business is
better than a business founded on a
friendship when we give someone our time
we actually give a portion of our life
that we will never take
back it is unrealistic to expect people
to see you as you see
yourself you attract what you are you
want to attract better become
better spend time with the
elderly their wisdom and experiences are
invaluable
small
circle private life and peaceful
mind never bend your head always hold it
high look the world straight in the
eye never be afraid to treat people the
way they treat
you when they give you lined paper right
the other
way rules for happiness something to do
someone to love something to hope
for life gives you lemons pepper salt
and sometimes cold water but they don't
come together or in a certain order so
keep struggling until the lemonade is
ready
you can either be a negative or positive
person in life but only one will get you
somewhere whoever fights can lose
whoever doesn't fight has already
lost nature have given men one tongue
but two
ears that we may hear from others twice
as as much as we
speak take a deep breath it's just a bad
day not a bad
life people will forget what you
said people will forget what you
did but people will never forget how you
made them
feel things that will
count you your health and your
achievements the first step to getting
anywhere is deciding you're not willing
to stay where you
are the true test of a man's character
is what he does when no one is
watching one day or day one you
decide
much is expected from that to whom much
is
given don't say
someday say now for someday may never
come you will be disappointed and
heartbroken multiple times but it's how
you respond that
matters donate to charity small acts
change
lives life is a boxing game defeat is
not declared when you fall down it is
declared when you refuse to get
up use
things not people love people not
things time is your most valuable
resource there are no refunds or second
chances for the time you
waste being in patient with actions but
patient with
results don't be emotionally attached to
anyone people change even your best
friends May probably turn into strangers
one
day they've promised that dreams can can
come
true but forgot to mention that
nightmares are dreams
too every Journey Begins With the first
step in order to empathize with
someone's experience you must be willing
to believe them as they see it and not
how you imagine their experience to
be do not look back when
leaving there are 1,000 lessons in
defeat but only one in
Victory waste no more time arguing about
what a good man should
be be
one you make the best decisions when in
pain because fear of experiencing the
same pain again is the the strongest
motivator don't let anyone ever make you
feel like you don't deserve what you
want you've got to do what's right for
you even if it hurts some people you
love when anger Rises think of the
consequences the fact that people do not
learn from the mistakes of history is
the most important lesson of
history no wise man ever wished to be
[Music]
younger since we're all going to
die it's obvious that when and how don't
matter learn to cook a few basic dishes
is it's a valuable life
skill any thought you have about the
future is a
delusion you're going to make a lot of
people mad doing what's right for
you you can't cross the ocean until you
lose sight of the
shore it's easy to fool someone it's
hard to convince them that they've been
fooled at your life's darkest moments
you'll see the most
clearly do not postpone joy for the sake
of the future the tomorrow is promised
to no
one the hardest part is at the beginning
of the journey the rocket Los loses 90%
of its fuel during
takeoff
breathe it's just a bad day not a bad
life things will get
better just
wait people in essence do not grow up
they only get
old you can hide memories but you can't
erase the history that produced
them the way you treat others reflects
who you are not who they
are not everyone will make it to your
future some people are passing through
to teach you life
lessons in the face of adversity
remember that Diamonds Are Made under
pressure
Embrace Solitude as a time for
reflection and
self-discovery not everyone you trust
will be
trustworthy don't be afraid to express
vulnerability it shows
strength learn to handle rejection
gracefully it's a part of
life control your finances or lack of
them will control
you out of your vulnerabilities will
come your
strength if a man is as wise as a
serpent he can afford to be as harmless
as a
dove rule your mind or it will rule
you no matter how hard you work you
can't have everything you want
eventually most of us end up settling in
some part of our
life before you speak let your words
pass through three
gates is it true is it
kind is it
necessary
you are not unique there will always be
someone else equally attractive fun and
qualified to replace
you time never Waits it only urges you
to catch up or get left
behind a moment of patience in a moment
of anger saves from a thousand minutes
of
regret
we stopped looking for monsters under
our bed when we realized that they were
inside
us never tolerate
disrespect not even from
yourself create and stick to a personal
budget worrying is like a rocking chair
it gives you something to do but gets
you
nowhere you can't start the next chapter
of your life if you keep rereading the
last
one the best view comes after the
hardest
climb courage doesn't always
Roar sometimes it's the quiet voice at
the end of the day saying I will try
again
tomorrow your ambition is handicapped by
laziness never lose your sense of humor
laughter is the best medicine for the
soul you'll never find a rainbow if
you're looking
down always pay off your credit card
debt it'll save you trouble
later the best revenge is massive
success the more you give the more you
receive the heart that shares is the
heart that's
full if you can dream it you can do
it stop telling people more than they
need to
know you meet every single person for a
reason just let it be if it's meant to
be it will
happen your past was never a mistake if
you learned from
it receive without conceit
release without
struggle the secret to being creative
alone ideas are born in
loneliness don't wait for the right
opportunity create
it do not say a little in many
words but a great deal in a
few
whether it's a machine a house or a
relationship maintenance is always
cheaper than
repairing you may not lead a comfortable
life with a single source of
income you need to build
others the meaning of life is to give
life
meaning
whatever advice you give be
brief a man only begins to be valued
when he is no longer
there a ship is safe in Harbor but
that's not what ships are
for once you feel free someone avoids
you never disturb them them
again no man is free who is not a master
of
himself Gardens are not made by singing
oh how
beautiful and sitting in the
shade judge a man by his questions
rather than by his
answers
who of You by worrying can add a single
hour to his
life always take responsibility for your
actions for it is the mark of a mature
individual it's okay to make
mistakes mistakes mean you're
trying people willingly they believe
what they want to
believe 10 people who speak make more
noise than 10,000 who are
silent the days that break you are the
days that make
you your respect at most places is
directly proportional to your bank
balance
it takes a long time to realize how
truly miserable you are and even longer
to realize it doesn't have to be that
way honesty without kindness is
brutality kindness without honesty is
manipulation courage doesn't always
Roar sometimes it is a quiet voice at
the end of the day
saying I will try again
tomorrow Never Wrestle with a pig you
both will get dirty but the pig likes
it a denied expectation hurts more than
a denied hope while a fulfilled hope
makes us happier than a fulfilled
expectation
life is 10% what happens to us and
90% how we react to
it people often confuse stress with
responsibility that mountain you've been
carrying you were only supposed to
climb you cannot have a positive life
and a negative mind
the most Exquisite pleasure is giving
pleasure to
others it's not about having what you
want but wanting what you
have do not let the shadows of your past
darken the doorstep of your
future sometimes we create our own
heartbreaks through
expectation even the smallest lie can
break the biggest
trust be kind and generous without
expecting anything in
[Music]
return make more moves and less
announcements we learn not in school but
in
life you can never be overdressed or
overeducated smile today is The Tomorrow
you worried about
yesterday luck is what happens when
preparation meets
opportunity better to be thought a fool
than to open your mouth and remove all
doubt don't let perfect be the enemy of
good anger is an acid that can do more
harm to the vessel in which it is stored
than to anything on which it is
poured you can't always have a good day
but you can always face a bad day with a
good
attitude owning your truth can be hard
but not nearly as hard is spending your
life running away from
it he who wishes to be obeyed must know
how to
command a donkey loaded with gold will
open the gates of any
Fortress
any fool can
know the point is to
understand doubt kills more dreams than
failure ever
will celebrate small victories and
Milestones because they pave the way for
bigger
achievements trust yourself you've
survived a lot and you'll survive
whatever is
coming the point of the argument is not
to defeat each other but to understand
each
other fake love is mighty convincing in
a world where real love is mighty
rare recognizing a problem is half the
success in solving
it
perceive failure as a vulnerable teacher
and a stepping stone to
success Embrace every opportunity for
regrets come from the chances we didn't
take no gains without
pains don't cling to a mistake just
because you spend a lot of time making
it I guess it comes down to a simple
Choice
really get busy living or get busy
dying progress is impossible without
change compromise is the best and
cheapest
lawyer
knowing yourself is the beginning of all
wisdom believe in yourself and the rest
will fall into
place never fall in love with the same
person twice because the second time you
fall in love with the memories not the
person some things are meant to cross
your way
but are not meant to
stay your direction is more important
than your
speed worrying only means you suffer
twice be
afraid but do it
anyway sometimes
loneliness is the price you pay for
growth
don't wait for the perfect moment take
it and make it
perfect never think twice about
investments in
yourself they pay dividends for a long
time you will never remember the days
and nights you stay home and do
nothing
sometimes Which choice you make is not
as important as making a choice and
committing to
it don't compare yourself to others
because no one can play Your Role better
than
you whoever brings you the most peace
should get the most
time patience is
power
you are who you
are nobody's approval is
needed the harder your past was the more
beautiful your future will
be if you get tired learn to rest not to
quit no relationship is worth damaging
ing your mental
health depend on yourself never on
others being too nice breaks
you expect nothing and you will never
get
disappointed just be real it saves
everyone's
time
putting off until tomorrow is your
weakness one day or day one you
decide we are our
choices the past is just a story We Tell
ourselves a salary is the drug that they
give you to forget your
dreams you miss 100% of the shots you
don't
take it never gets easy but it gets
easier if you need music on the beach
you're missing the
point we live longer when we are too
busy living
the people who mind don't matter and the
people who matter don't
mind keep breaking your heart until it
opens remember when you wanted what you
currently
have no expectations no disappointment
ments one looking into a puddle sees
dirt in it the other stars reflected in
it begin be bold and venture to be
wise if each of us sweeps right under
our feet the whole world will be
[Music]
clean
an abnormal reaction to an abnormal
situation is normal
behavior do not judge or you too will be
judged the first man gets the
oyster the second man gets the
shell an explained joke is no longer
longer a
joke never put off till tomorrow the fun
you can have
today the Liar's punishment is not in
the least that he has not believed but
that he cannot believe anyone
else marrying is not at all difficult it
is difficult
to be
married pay attention to the negative
signs that people give off and
immediately disconnect from
them it will save you a lot of pain and
more
importantly wasted
time the only person who's ever going to
remember your hard work is you not this
company not not your boss only you it's
not worth killing yourself over a
company that'll replace you in two days
if you're
gone never regret a day in your life
good days give happiness bad days give
experience worse days give
lessons and best days give
memories
any person capable of angering you
becomes your master he can anger you
only when you permit yourself to be
disturbed by
him no woman or man really knows what
perfect love is until they have been
married a quarter of a
century a wise man gets more use from
his enemies than a fool from his
friends when talking to people look them
in the eye and on the face this will
make you more confident in front of
others your self-respect has to be
stronger than your
feelings don't tell your friends that
you're
happy don't make them
angry don't tell your enemies that
you're
unhappy don't make them
happy there never exists a relationship
without
self-interest in short every one of us
for sure is
selfish never expect too high the more
you expect when it doesn't meet your
expectation the more it's going to
hurt if you are a giver remember to
learn your limits because the takers
don't have
any your deepest darkest moment may be
the best thing that ever happens to
you there is nothing more important to
true growth than realizing that you are
not the voice of the
mind you are the one who hears
it great minds discuss ideas average
Minds discuss
events small minds discuss
people the most important thing we learn
at school is the fact that the most
important things can't be learned at
school
whatever the mind can conceive and
believe it can
achieve danger is very real but fear is
a
choice don't ruin your health in order
to earn money you will end up spending
your money to recover your health and
that is not reciprocal
sometimes you need to stop seeing the
good in people and start seeing what
they show
you leave the house messy in the yard
unmowed for the weekend you will
remember the fun not the clean house or
yard make time for
fun you learn nothing from life if you
think you're right all the
time sometimes we're tested not to show
our
weaknesses but to discover our
strengths people only want to hear the
good not the bad so if you have issues
it'll be hard to find people to confide
in time passes slowly when you follow it
it senses being
followed you spend your first 20 years
worrying what people think about you you
spend your next 20 years swearing that
you don't care what people think about
you you spend the next 20 years
realizing that they aren't thinking
about
you
stop letting other people take advantage
of you learn to say no and understand
your
rights when you do things right people
won't be sure you've done anything at
all a happy marriage is a long
conversation which always seems too
short work on you for
you if you're not dating to marry you're
dating for
heartbreak let that sink in and be in a
serious
relationship the calmer you are the
clearer you
think don't pretend to be better than
you are live life at your own
pace life is too short to waste time
hating
anyone Envy is a waste of
time you already have all you
need action is 10 times more valuable
than reading and
planning experience is the best teacher
you might regret your speech but you'll
never regret your
silence if you're going to try go all
the
way otherwise don't even
start do more the race is won by the
horse that outstrips its Rivals by a
head
wisdom is not wisdom when it is derived
from books
alone it is indeed very hard to move on
but once you do you'll realize it was
your best
decision be the person you needed when
you were
younger everybody wants to go to heaven
but nobody wants to
die accept criticism but never accept
disrespect you can't change the past but
can shape your future by learning from
it when you stop chasing the wrong
things the right ones catch
up never awaken a woman's love with no
intention of loving
her a lesson never ever goes away until
it has taught us what we need to
know learn to say no Be
Frugal eat only real food no wheat and
limit
carbs if you don't CLE fear your
misunderstanding in time they become the
reason for distance
forever we are all the bad guy in
someone's
story never close your lips to Those
whom you have already opened your heart
to to be angry is to take revenge on
oneself
for the mistakes of
others there is nothing impossible to
him who will
try thinking that someone else can make
you happy or unhappy is
ridiculous you can overcome bad habits
only today not
tomorrow
to lead people follow
them it is better to make approximately
correct decision than to make a precise
mistake respect yourself because people
can see if you
don't the more you know the Dumber you
sound to stupid
people
don't let success go to your head don't
let failure go to your
heart the best way to respect yourself
is to discipline
yourself don't waste your time with
explanations people only hear what they
want to
hear to be the best
you must be able to handle the
worst as long as you are alive no
obstacle is
permanent many of the people you told
your secret to have already told it to
others the walls you build to keep
things out are also keeping things
in
learn to let go even if you are
right never make a promise you can't
keep do not fear getting
hurt you can't grow if you don't
hurt experience is the teacher of all
things
the shortest distance between two points
is often
unbearable any man can make mistakes but
only an idiot persists in his
error how much money does it take to
make a man
happy just one more
dollar stay patient
the best things happen
unexpectedly life is a one-time offer
use it
well be kind to people without allowing
them to take advantage of your good
nature efforts never go in
vain
how others see you is not
important how you see yourself means
everything never let others know your
weaknesses instead always try to show up
your
positives in order to love who you are
you can cannot hate the experiences that
shaped
you it's better to be alone than in Bad
Company you never know how strong you
are until being strong is the only
choice you
have if you're not happy with yourself
you'll never be happy in a
relationship it is better to light one
small candle than to curse the
darkness men are moved by two levers
only fear and
self-interest a River cuts through Rock
not because of its
power but because of its
persistence just trust your instincts
gut feelings can sometimes times save
you from big
troubles stupid is the man who always
Remains the
Same learn first teach
later the heaviest burden we carry is
the weight of our
expectations there are no shortcuts to
any place worth going
do not let what you cannot do interfere
with what you can
do the best way to gain self-confidence
is to do what you are afraid to
do no one in this world will stand up
for you like the way your parents do
always be there for
them being lonely and being alone are
different
things most people are a complete waste
of
time don't let people know too much
about
you you don't get extra marks for
putting up with people you
dislike you don't have to be great to
start but to become great you just have
to
start the world belongs to the
patient time
flies one day you are 30 the next you
are
50 plan now for what you want 50 to look
like never compete with someone who has
nothing to lose
knowledge isn't power until it is
applied ask no questions and you'll be
told no
lies he who is satisfied with his lot is
Rich Do Not Shake the green apple tree
when the apple is ripe it will fall down
by
itself be equally indifferent to blame
and
praise to lead an orchestra you must
turn your back on the
crowd he who builds on the people Builds
on the
mud treat your parents as you would like
your children to treat
you work at your job and make a
living work on yourself and make a
fortune bad habits are like a
comfortable bed easy to get into but
hard to get out
of the strongest people are not those
who show strength and in front of us but
those who fight battles we know nothing
about a good laugh and a long sleep are
the two best cures for
anything take your financial life
seriously money is a defense to a lot of
challenges being alone gives us an
opportunity to reconnect with
ourselves someone once told me the
meaning of
hell on your last day on the earth the
person you became will meet the person
you could have
become you train people how to treat you
unconsciously or
not don't die until you're
done there's no point in being grown up
if you can't act a little childish
sometimes it is not the critic who
counts not the man who points out how
the strong man
stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done them
better the credit belongs to the man who
was actually in the arena whose face is
marred by dust and sweat and
blood we all love ourselves more than
other people but care more about their
opinion than our
own the oldest shortest words yes and no
are those which require the most thought
be kind for everyone you meet is
fighting a harder
battle to put everything in balance is
good to put everything in harmony is
better develop success from
failures discouragement and failure are
two of the shest Stepping Stones to
success
striving for Success without hard work
is like trying to harvest where you
haven't
planted turn your wounds into
wisdom forgiveness is not for the other
person it's for your peace of
mind life is often very
ambiguous sometimes there isn't a right
or wrong decision or
Choice things are not always completely
clear you may not get the answer so you
just have to wing
it to realize that you are not your
thoughts is when you begin to awaken
spiritually never attribute to malice
that which can be adequately explained
by
stupidity fairy tales are more than true
not because they tell us that dragons
exist but because they tell us that
dragons can be
beaten never go to the
Past not for happiness not for
justification
not for
excuses the world is what it is you are
what you
are Success is Not final failure is not
fatal it is the courage to continue that
counts do not worry about tomorrow for
tomorrow will worry about
itself each day has enough trouble of
its
own of all the Liars in the
world sometimes the worst are our own
fears do not spoil what you have by
Desiring what you have
not remember that what you now have was
once among the things you only hope
for
you don't have to burn books to destroy
a culture just get people to stop
reading
them don't look back you are not going
that
way practice
self-compassion we are all human and
everyone makes
mistakes if you tell the truth you don't
have to remember
anything make and keep friends with the
people you want to
emulate not the people that you think
will be most likely to accept
you the people you associate with Will
shape your
future start saving your money don't
spend it on homes you can't afford fancy
cars and running your credit cards to
the
max in the end you'll be much
happier there are two paths you can go
by but in the long run there's still
time to change the road you're
on it's no use wasting time worrying
what other people think about you no one
is thinking about
you the world is a tragedy to those who
feel but aomed to those who
think thinking is the hardest work there
is which is probably the reason why so
few engage in
it there are only three events in a
man's life birth life and death
he is not conscious of being born he
dies in pain and he forgets to
live manage your mood because if it does
not obey then it
commands in order to understand the
world one has to turn away from it on
occasion
if it is not right do not do it if it is
not true do not say
it true love never has a happy
ending because there is no ending to
true
love life is like a book some chapters
are sad some are happy but all are
necessary for the full
story take good care of your health
without Health nothing will matter no
amount of money can bring you Joy if you
are
suffering always move in your own
Direction not according to society
friends or
family
what other people think of you is none
of your
business it is not a lack of
time it is a lack of
priority through discipline comes
freedom to know your
enemy you must become your
enemy
children learn by an adult's example not
by their
words never Overlook
contempt when someone views you with
contempt and talks to you like you're
beneath them they will likely do you
harm whether relationally socially or
physically remove that person from your
life
life is far from over but it's very
short
too if you want to do something don't
delay but don't sacrifice what you want
for what you want right
now this is your world shape it or
someone else
will the best thing I ever did
was stop telling people what's going on
in my
life be proud of how hard you are
trying at your lowest you realize a
lot no one is too busy it's only a
matter of
priorities never Force don't beg and
don't
chase learn how to change a flat tire on
your
vehicle if you don't value your time
neither will
others the pain you feel today will be
the strength you feel
tomorrow don't put off important medical
checkups
Time Heals almost
everything give it
time sometimes you win sometimes you
learn if it keeps you happy keep it
quiet if nobody helps you do it
alone Be selfish with your time a lot of
people don't deserve
it you can't go back and change the
beginning but you can start where you
are and change the
ending if you don't ask you don't
get do unto others as you would have
them do unto
you
life isn't fair but it's still
good he who is not courageous enough to
take risks will accomplish Nothing in
life never take the responsibility that
does not belong to
you have firm boundaries and be
Discerning about who you you let into
your
life buy real estate land anything you
can
afford the less possessions you own the
happier and less burden you will have in
your
life don't leave someone to teach them a
lesson leave because you learned
yours when in doubt just take the next
small
step be careful who you marry and even
more careful who you have kids
with slow down and realize that mistakes
are essential to learning
anything get yourself together before
you get any older the older you are the
harder it is to
change no one cares except
family nothing is actually as bad as it
seems or as great as you think it will
be it is good to be generous benign and
magnanimous but there's a limit or
you'll be taken for
granted holding on to things will always
make you more
stressed things won't happen in a
certain way just because you want them
to happen that
way learn from what people do not from
what they tell
you don't react in Anger
immediately wait for it to
subside what's said or done in Anger is
irreversible see people for who they are
not who you you need them to
be never jump to
conclusions be Discerning and let people
show you their true
colors never lend money because you
might lend it to friends for a few days
but retrieve it from Fools for
years never share your problems with
friends before finding a solution no
matter matter how challenging it
is don't show your
weaknesses people will enjoy the
show don't be weak in front of
them listen to the people who tell you
what you don't want to
hear self-pity is dangerous stay away
from
it
just because you are going through hell
right now doesn't mean you will never
smile
again pain is purely
temporary the only constant in life is
change embrace it and you'll
grow say please and thank you
often there there is no elevator to
success you have to take the
stairs quietly work let success speak
up what would you do if you weren't
afraid hard work beats Talent when
talent doesn't work
hard the days are long the years are
short heard this after I had my first
kid couldn't be more
true the reason you want to be better
than someone else is the reason why you
aren't no one raindrop thinks it causes
the
flood better to remain silent and be
thought a fool R than to speak out and
remove all
doubt do what you can with what you have
where you
are words can be like x-rays if you use
them
properly they'll go through
anything you read and you're
pierced everyone one sees what you
appear to be few experience what you
really
are a man who dares to waste one hour of
time has not discovered the value of
life if your hate could be turned into
electricity it would light up the whole
world
socializing is just like any skill you
need to practice before you're good at
it tact is The Knack of making a point
without making an
enemy just because you got away with a
bad decision doesn't make it a good
decision live as if you were to die
tomorrow
learn as if you were to live
forever life is like a play it's not the
length but the Excellence of the acting
that
matters people don't forget nothing gets
forgiven he who does not like
loneliness does not like
freedom
you are either part of the problem or
part of the
[Music]
solution life is not a problem to be
solved but a reality to be
experienced in times of war the law
Falls
silent things are only impossible until
they are
not no man becomes rich unless he
enriches
others I've had a lot of worries in my
life most of which never
happened when in doubt tell the
truth graveyard is full of people who
used to think that the world could not
run without
them the moment poverty walks in through
the door love and peace toss themselves
out of the
window a friend is a gift you give
yourself things work out when you least
expect them life has a funny way of
surprising us when we're not looking for
it anything you can settle with money is
cheap men cheat because they don't feel
needed women because they don't feel
loved the more we value things outside
our
control the less control we
have
don't make hopes hopes will create
expectation and expectation makes you
weaker no one cares except you do what
lifts you up in your eyes what people
say does not
matter a winner is a dreamer who never
gives
up if you want the present to be
different from the past study the
past be forgiving be understanding but
do not be a
[Music]
fool no regrets just
lessons no worries just
acceptance no
expectations just
gratitude life is too
short
the one charm of the past is that it is
in the
past the LIE flies and the truth limps
after
it respect yourself and others will
respect
you without courage wisdom Bears no
fruit
we must bring our own light to the
darkness don't let yesterday use up too
much of
today the best is always the enemy of
the
good you can't litter negativity
everywhere and wonder why you have a
trashy
life
betrayal never comes from your
enemies regretting won't change your
past and it will end up your future if
you continue to do
that some people just won't admit
they're wrong don't waste time trying to
get them to accept
it sometimes you just have to let stupid
people will be
stupid if you treat an individual as he
is he will remain how he is but if you
treat him as if he were what he ought to
be and could be he will become what he
ought to be and could
be keep busy it's the cheapest kind of
medicine there is on this Earth and one
of the best
your friend's problems become your
problems the smaller your circle the
less you have to deal
with when you were born you cried and
the world
rejoiced live your life so that when you
die the world
cries and you
rejoice
a bad phase of your life can start at
any
time genius is 1% talent and
99% hard
work the noblest work of
God man who found it out
man save a little money every week or
month nothing gives you happiness like a
financial buffer Believe It or
Not happiness is not something you
postpone for the future it is something
you design for the
present life moves pretty fast if you
don't stop and look around you could
miss it
the thing you think about determined the
quality of your
mind do your best and Trust the
process the harder you work the luckier
you will
get your heart will tell you where to
go your head will guide you there safely
use one without the other
and you'll get
lost throw off your worries when you
throw off your clothes at
night often the lies that are
believed become the
truth if you want to live a happy life
tie it to a goal not to people or
things
never give up on something you really
want it's difficult to wait but it's
more difficult to
regret you can't do big things if you
are distracted by Small
Things focus on what you can control and
let go of what you
cannot a clever person solves a problem
a wise person avoids
it most so-called failures are only
temporary
defeats life isn't about finding
yourself life is about creating
yourself it's not what happens to you
but how you react to it that matter
matters intuition is something that is
ahead of accurate
knowledge one can always be kind to
people about whom one cares
nothing nothing costs so much in life as
illness and ignoring an
illness everything outside of this
moment is just
imagination your life does not get
better by chance it gets better by
change stay strong even when things
Begin to Fall Apart stay
strong I would rather be a swin herd
understood by the swine than and a poet
misunderstood by
men fear doesn't exist anywhere except
in the
mind you'll never be sorry for telling
someone you love them do it before it's
too
late you can tell more about a person by
what he says about others than you can
by what others say about
him to get married means to have your
rights and double your
responsibilities you will be pulled down
out of
jealousy don't get surprised it's
normal most of the time you have to
swallow the pain and learn to grow up by
yourself trust
wisely and not
blindly Here for a Good
Time not a long
time a fool is known by his speech and a
wise man by
silence one today day is worth two
tomorrow's our thoughts make us what we
are difficulty shows what men
are the life of the Dead is set in the
memory of the
living never take anything
personally what others say can do is a
projection of their own
reality the more you are interested in
others the more interesting they find
you to be interesting be
interested the only time you should ever
look back is to see how far you've
come Embrace stress as the opposite of
apathy
when someone shows you who they are
believe them the first
time a leader is a dealer in
Hope keep your fears to
yourself but share your courage with
others when you work for someone else
you have the right only to
labor not to the fruits of your
labor true love begins when nothing is
looked for in
return don't read a quote and say this
is wise but read a quote and say how can
I relate this to my
life better 50% now than 100% %
never if it ain't broke don't fix
it you're being judged no matter what so
be who you want to
be wealth is like seawater the more we
drink the thirstier we
become and the same is true of Fame
what Paul says about Peter tells us more
about Paul than about
[Music]
Peter difficulties strengthen the mind
as labor does the
body the truth is everyone is going to
hurt you you just got to find the ones
worth suffering
for
be loyal or stay
single that's
simple never say maybe if you want to
say
no when you are angry Stay
silent you don't have to win every
argument agree to
disagree
at some point you will realize no one
else has a say in your life unless you
let
them you are confined only by the walls
you build
yourself where your fear is there is
your
task if you can't do great things do
small things in a a great
way when you work for someone else you
have the right only to
labor not to the fruits of your
labor children make so much noise you
can't think but when they leave the
house forever the silence is
maddening nonviolence is a weapon of the
Str
wrong no matter how thin you slice it
there will always be two
sides anything you dream is fiction and
anything you accomplish is
science the whole history of mankind is
nothing but science
fiction if a man knows not to which Port
he sails no wind is
favorable live every day as your
last because one of these days it will
be only those who can afford not to
lie are
free he who is to be a good
ruler must have first been ruled
the greatest risk is not taking
one an ounce of prevention is worth a
pound of
cure give without expecting anything in
return you need to stop the habit of
doubting
yourself waiting for change while not
doing anything for it is like waiting
for the train at a bus
stop a blind man is a poor guide until
it gets
dark we have two lives and the second
begins when we realize we only have
one it's not your fault things are the
way they are
you can't wait for
inspiration you have to go after it with
a
club remember 5 years ago you dreamed
about being where you are
now think about
it if you can't explain it to a six-year
old you don't understand it
yourself
life will only come around once so do
whatever makes you
happy those who are hardest to love need
it the
most what one man calls God another
calls the laws of
physics hatred is a curse that does not
affect the hated it only poisons the
hater release a grudge as if it was
poison never tell your friends your
plans stop putting too much trust in
them don't let anyone know what you're
doing until it's
done time always exposes what you truly
mean to
someone be correct with everyone
sociable with many close to the elect
friend to the
few it is nothing to die it is frightful
not to
live if a woman is angry it means she is
not only wrong but also she knows
it if someone is trying to bring you
down they are already below
you time always exposes what you truly
mean to
someone even the finest sword plunged
into salt water will eventually
rust not everybody wants to be your
friend and that's okay
you really don't want everybody as a
friend
anyway what we do now echoes in
eternity do the hard Jobs first the easy
jobs will take care of
themselves if you can survive your own
thoughts you can survive anything
thing love your enemies for they tell
you your
faults that which does not kill us makes
us
stronger
procrastination is the thief of
time caller
it one day in retrospect
the years of struggle will strike you as
the most
beautiful what we learn from history is
that no one learns from
history Who Dares nothing needs Hope For
Nothing learn to heal without venting to
everyone failure is a bruise not a
tattoo be careful who you
trust salt and sugar look the
same money is a tool not the goal
freedom is the
goal stay calm you've been through this
before you'll get through it
again learn to say no without explaining
yourself believe nothing you hear and
only one half that you
see the Saints are the Sinners who keep
on
trying Above All Things respect
yourself do what no one else can do and
you will become what no one else can
become value experience over possessions
because memories are the real Treasures
of
Life give back even if it's donating
your tag sale leftovers or handing a
dollar bill over to someone less
fortunate do it it'll make you feel
good women are meant to be loved not to
be
understood lead from the back and let
others believe they are in
front love is an irresistible desire to
be irresistibly
desired by failing to prepare you are
preparing to
fail intellect is invisible to the man
who has
none do yourself a favor get rich life
gets easier with money not
time
if they don't appreciate you they don't
deserve
you to avoid disappointment expect
nothing from
nobody avoid gossip at all costs it's
poison to your
mind the root of all suffering is
attachment stress is temporary but the
lessons you learn from it can last a
lifetime money isn't everything in life
but it can help you solve a lot of
problems the future comes slowly the
present
flies and the past stands still
forever to be every everywhere is to be
nowhere the greatest Victory is victory
over
yourself if you are not falling down
occasionally you are just
coasting forget what hurts you but never
forget what it taught
you the only way to live like a king is
to work like a
slave
everyone at some time or
another sits down to a banquet of
consequences you came into this huge
world alone and will go out of it
alone hence can make any any impossible
thing possible by yourself
only appear weak when you are strong and
strong when you are
weak seek wisdom not
knowledge knowledge is of the past
wisdom is of the
future give a man power and you will
find out who he
is you are responsible for your own
happiness if you expect others to make
you happy you will always be
disappointed you don't always have to be
going being and
doing it's really okay to just
chill
who controls the past controls the
future who controls the present controls
the
past smart people learn from everything
and
everyone average people from their
experiences stupid people already have
all the
answers above all things never be
afraid the enemy who forces you to
retreat is himself afraid of you at that
very
moment except what is let go of what
was have faith in what will
be remember some things have to end for
better things to begin
if you wish to forget anything on the
spot make a note that this thing is to
be
remembered things may come to those who
wait but only the things left by those
who
hustle education is the most powerful
weapon which you can use to change the
world
have at least one person in your life
who gives you honest
opinions be a good person but don't
waste your time proving
it do Every Act of your life as though
it were the very last Act of your
life whoever violated trust once loses
it from
forever everything happens for a
reason
always mastering others is
strength mastering yourself is true
power he suffers more than necessary who
suffers before it is
necessary
fear of death increases in exact
proportion to increase in
wealth your enemies can kill you but
only your friends can hurt
you if a man knows more than others he
becomes
lonely life is like riding a bicycle to
keep your balance you must keep
moving success is stumbling from failure
to failure with no loss of
enthusiasm nothing is particularly hard
if you divide it into small
jobs a negative mind will never give you
a positive
life
drop by drop is the water pot filled
likewise the wise man Gathering it
little by little fills himself with
good everything you need will come to
you at the perfect
time if you want to be trusted be honest
people who say it cannot be done should
not interrupt those who are doing
it wealth consists not in having great
possessions but in having few
wants a goal without a plan is just a
wish we suffer more in imagination than
in
reality He Who Walks straight rarely
Falls life will separate you from your
friends so appreciate each moment you
have
together women make even the men more
sophisticated do not chase after
happiness it is always in
you hope for the best prepare for the
worst good things do come to those who
wait and suffer it might take time and
be a long and rough
road but it's completely and totally
worth
it you will look back at your life with
much more regret for the things that you
didn't do than for the things that you
did a profession should initially be an
act of love and not a marriage of
convenience better days are coming you
won't always wake up in the morning with
a heavy
heart
worry doesn't take away tomorrow's
troubles it takes away today's
peace the man who does more than he is
paid for will soon be paid for more than
he
does don't
react cut them off
silently genius is is a mind that knows
its
limits your strongest muscle and worst
enemy is your mind train it
well so in everything do to others what
you would have them do to
you anyone you love can die
anytime cherish them
time is
money trust is easy to build but can be
shattered in
seconds Fortune accompanies the
Brave the more you spend clinging to the
past the less likely your future will be
any
brighter
Perfection is achieved not when there is
nothing more to
add but when there is nothing left to
take
away he who has a why to live for can
bear almost any
how The Art of Living Well and the Art
of dying well are
one
it is not the man who has too little but
the man who craves more that is
poor if you can make a girl laugh you
can make her do
anything your direction is more
important than your
speed if you waste money you can earn it
again if you miss the moment it can
never be
returned live life with opened eyes ears
and
heart never ruin an apology with an
excuse it always seems impossible until
it's
done don't ever let the same people
disappoint point point you
twice there is no better way to save
yourself than saving money every
day compound interest can do
wonders keep your mouth shut whenever
you are
happy keep your mouth shut whenever you
are
sad things don't make us happy
experiences
do the way to get started is to quit
talking and begin
doing real men despise battle but will
never run from
it there is truth in wine and
children
people want you to
succeed but not more than
themselves hard times will always reveal
true
friends stop comparing yourself with
those who started 10 years before
you focus on your own
Journey
Simplicity is the result of
maturity education is what remains after
one has forgotten what one has learned
in
school the Journey of a Thousand Miles
begins with a single
step learning to let go should be
learned from learning to
get
it does not require many words to speak
the
truth choose your friends
wisely the fastest way to become better
is to surround yourself with better
people don't be afraid to make a hard
Choice the hard choices are the best you
end up
making
nothing is ever as easy as it
seems a person who doesn't make mistakes
doesn't make anything at
all anyone who has never made a mistake
has never tried anything
new the hard work of the future will be
pushing
buttons
nothing makes a man so adventurous as an
empty
pocket the future depends on what you do
today the time for Action is now it's
never too late to do
something be the change that you wish to
see in the world
someone else's progress doesn't make
yours any
less even the nicest people have their
limits if you punish the
truth expect to be lied
to only he who controls himself is free
if you cannot have a faithful friend be
your own
friend laziness travels so slowly that
poverty soon overtakes
him other people's stupidity never makes
us
smart seek respect not attention
it lasts
longer so many people love you don't
focus on the people who
don't your vision will be
blurry but it will grow clear with
time patience is your
ally never forget who who helped you in
a difficult
time both optimists and pessimists
contribute to
society The Optimist invents the
airplane the pessimist the
parachute laws are like cobwebs which
may catch small flies but let wasps and
hornets break
through
he travels the fastest who travels
alone genius lies in the ability to
distinguish the difficult from The
Impossible the truth is putting its
shoes
on last but not
least you are here for a reason that you
may not know
but be patient you beat a billion odds
by being here be grateful for the little
things in life that others take for
granted there will always be someone who
doesn't see your
worth don't let it be
you life did not intend to make us
perfect whoever is perfect belongs in a
museum what we know is a drop what we
don't know is an
ocean no
regrets just do better next
time before you are old attend as many
funerals as you can bear and listen
nobody talks about the departed's
achievements the only thing people will
remember is what kind of person you were
while you were
achieving just because you miss someone
doesn't mean you need them back in your
life missing is a part of getting
over ignorance is the root and stem of
every evil
never interrupt your enemy when he is
making a
mistake take care of your body remember
health is another form of
wealth you cannot change the direction
of the wind but you can adjust your
sales to reach your
destination
don't regret having a good heart all
good things come back and
multiply if you don't let go of the
wrong people you'll never meet the right
people don't feel guilty for doing
what's best for
you if you always do what you've always
done you'll always get what you've
always
got don't trust words trust
actions courage is not having the
strength to go
on it is going on when you don't have
the
strength there is nothing more
unbearable than
idleness
God knows when to send you exactly what
you
need don't make a permanent decision
based on temporary
emotions first it hurts then it makes
you
stronger no matter how hard the past you
can always begin
again
forgive your old self you've
changed don't judge your Greatness by
your Shadow at
Sunset a friend to all is a friend to
none a woman's guess is much more
accurate than a man's
certainty
he who is not satisfied with a little is
satisfied with
nothing understanding a question is half
an
answer how many things would you
attempt if you knew you could not
fail you alone are enough you have
nothing to prove to
anyone sometimes you have to go through
the worst to get the
best be alone until you're
valued don't
overshare privacy is
power be yourself people don't have to
like you and you you don't have to
care to be able to forget means
sanity free yourself from society's
advice most of them have no idea of what
they're
doing it is better to offer no
excuse than a bad
one everything that happens before death
is what
counts sometimes people don't want to
hear the truth because they don't want
their Illusions
destroyed the secret to success is to do
the common things uncommonly
well believe you can and your halfway
there the family you create is more
important than the family you come
from the best way to keep one's word is
not to give
it it is better to act and repent than
not to act and
regret trying to forget someone means
remembering him all the
time strong people are always
simple